premièrement c'est un nouveau vaisseau
dans le spacek se doit passer à travers
cette phase critique de son premier
amerrissage habiter pour pouvoir faire
certifier sa capsus la dernière phase de
certification
et puis donc ça c'est la première étape
de la réponse mais aussi la procédure va
changer je me souviens dans le temps des
missions apollo le haut après si on
arrêtait les amerrissages la dernière
message tu es en 75
ben la capsule amerrit c'est qu'on
allait la chercher on allait chercher
les astronautes directement avec un
petit radeau au louvre la question les
sortez le la procédure est différente
alors on va envoyer deux petits bateaux
on pourra aller chercher les parachutes
qui vont s'être détachée et un pour
allez allez voir qu'il n'ya pas de
résidus ou de vapeurs de carburant car
présente et ensuite de sao remorque
carrément la capitale avec les
astronautes de da on la met sur le
vaisseau principal de récupération on
l'a stabilisé c'est là qu'on va ouvrir
la ligue pour aller chercher les
astronautes
c'est une nouvelle procédure alors que
bon voilà que les parachutes se sont
déployées comme prévu et pourquoi cette
pratique là d'ailleurs a été abandonné
pendant aussi longtemps la presse parce
qu'on voulait oui la nasa voulait avoir
un vaisseau qu'au paiement réutilisables
la navette on l'a surnommé le camion de
l'espace c'est pas très poétique mais
c'était pour dire qu'on voulait y aller
souvent alexa soient réutilisables
alors le prototype si vous voulez ou les
modèles la navette spatiale à tirer
c'est comme un avion au sol puis donc on
a fait voler la navette spatiale pendant
35 ans ensuite des seuils à la période
de 10 ans où on était en développement
si vous voulez de ces nouveaux vaisseaux
spatiaux à du côté des états unis
donc on atterrissait sur terre avec les
soyouz les soyouz l'est en russie là ils
ont beaucoup plus de désert que d'eau à
proximité
non qu'ils atterrissent au sol et puis
donc eh oui est bon alors que l'on voit
ces images en direct donc tout semble se
dérouler comme prévu
oui alors l'on est en train de ralentir
la laquette laquelle seuls on a vu les
deux parachutes principe pour s'ouvrir
pour ralentir la capsule jusqu'à à peu
près le
v à peu près 200 km un peu moins en
dessous de sa c4 parachute là peuvent
s'ouvrir les quatre périodes principaux
qui vont permettre de ralentir la
capture jusqu'à environ 20 24 25 km
heure et puis là c'est là que ça va
toucher l'eau et quel peut être le délai
madame l'image entre le moment où la
capsule touche l'eau et le moment où les
astronautes sorte de cette capsule sont
secourus en fait parler les navires qui
viennent les récupérer
ça dépend toujours de la précision avec
laquelle on attire ici aux intéristes au
point prévu il ya des bateaux qui sont à
peine à une vingtaine de milles
nautiques qui vont aller les chercher
assez rapidement qu'ils le transportent
la procédure que je vous expliquais tout
à l'heure ça pourrait prendre environ 45
minutes à une heure toutes les six
tombes à l'endroit prévu
oui on l'a mentionné au cours des
dernières heures c'est le retour un peu
des américains sur sur la scène spatiale
internationale c'est la première fois en
dix ans très disant qu'ils font l'aller
retour à la station spatiale
internationale par eux-mêmes à bord d'un
vaisseau américain qui lui l'importance
de cette mission
l'important c'est les initiants ses
côtés point de vue américain c'est
l'autonomie on n'a plus besoin de
compter sur nos partenaires en russie
pourrait pour amener nos astronautes
dans l'espace
on sauve beaucoup de temps et d'argent
en entraînement aussi parce qu'on peut
les entraîner
aux états-unis comme david saint jacques
en les autres travaux qui doivent
piloter le soyouz doivent aller
s'entraîner en russie ça fait beaucoup
de déplacements puis de point de vue
strictement scientifique c'est
l'accélération de la science parce que
cet avis cette capsule en opère en et
quatre astronautes à la fois ça faisait
qu elle plutôt qu'envoyer un ou deux
astronautes américains
on peut non seulement multiplié les vols
parce que c'est moins cher mais on
pousse avec plus de gens dans l'espace
fut il ya dans ce roman dans la station
spatiale puis on fait sciences puis au
président et donc les mêmes objectifs
qui étaient
qui était visible avec les navettes
spatiales à l'époque alors que l'on voit
ces images ma foi spectaculaire de la
capsule qui a amerri avec succès donc
dans le golfe du mexique on voit un
navire qui s'approche pour aller
récupérer les astronautes
alors si réussie manal limoges oui très
très heureuse pour spacex très heureuse
parce que je voulais dire c'était la
phase finale pour ce pur facile et les
certifications ça veut probablement dire
on va attendre qu'ils aient tout est là
existaient dans la capsule mais ça veut
dire quatre astronautes qui vont pouvoir
parcourir pour le premier vrai vol
commercial de ce texte être c'est un
vol-test niveau de mai 68 pour vous il y
avait fait allusion donc en 2011 sous
l'administration obama la nasa a mis fin
aux navettes spatiales et s'est tourné
vers des entreprises privées pour leur
demander de développer un taxi spatiale
qui pouvait emmener des américains à la
station spatiale internationale spacek
ça a été la première à y arriver mais
est-ce que spacek se représente pour
autant l'avenir du programme spatial
américain
ils ont une longueur d'avancé certains
il ya aussi boeing à qui a eu le même
type de contrat donc ont engagé ce que
c'est que ces boeing pour développer la
partie tout que la nasa soit celles qui
développent que tu fais pour ce prix à
l'externe comme souvenir qu'à moi juste
donné le mandat pour suisse il devient
alors alors
puis selon atos discret d'intéressant
sur une version sage aurait plus de ce
précepte wings demande pas du
ravitaillement la station spatiale
enrichi des capsules et ils ont du
retard
donc en ce moment c'est vraiment le sexe
le kaiser dévoile comme question et
qu'il y ait un vous savez une fois
qu'ils ont livré leur partie du contrat
la nasa s'est avoué sur le site web
ça pourrait être assez rapide le 6
continents qui voulaient des beaux
succès comme celui
ouais donc vous parliez de vols
commerciaux c'est probablement la
prochaine étape clé pour spacex kelly
kelly l'échéancier les châssis pour pour
les voyageurs des lignes pour les
voyages à la station spatiale pour les
voyages vers la lune donc de spe 6 c'est
sûr qu'ils doivent avoir fini avec la
nasa mais on parlait de 20 fin juin
début et me paraît donc de vols
commerciaux vers la station spatiale
internationale dont qui pourrait se
réaliser dans les prochaines dans les
prochaines années dans les prochains
mois le prochain vol de ce que c'est que
ce serait donc habiter avec quatre
essais il ya un astronaute français je
crois qui a annoncé cette semaine
oui qu'il allait être du prochain vol de
spacek sont au printemps 2021 et vous ce
que j'avais vu c'est que c'était un
astronaute japonais mais peut-être que
mes informations sont pas à jour
mais oui en effet il y aura un membre
internationale si on s'entend là-dessus
puis 11 alors bon c'est un c'est un
succès sur toute la ligne donc pour vous
cette cette mission de spacex ces deux
astronautes qui était parti le 30 mai de
cap canaveral c'est certain qu'au nord
qu'ils ouvrent laquelle les
affrontements sont en bonne santé mais
mais oui et tout s'est bien passé ils
ont resté 62 jours dans l'espace
quatre matches dans l'espace pour bob
behnken les deux il est entré dans le
groupe des dix matches dans l'espace qui
ont fait jusqu'à d'engueuler à manipuler
le bras canadien ils ont participé pour
moi le succès de la mission bon il ya la
partie test le conte dont on parle peu
foiré christ et la capsule mais aussi
qu'ils ont qu est ce que ce sont les
attentes des vétérans sont installés
depuis 2000 ils ont pu prendre part à la
mission comme n'importe quel astronautes
ont entré lyon participe à la recherche
scientifique et on marche dans l'espace
et puis c'est ce qui est agréable c'est
on a trouvé un nouveau moyen d'accélérer
les vols dans l'espace de manière
d'affaires intégré au programme
d'exploration spatiale
ouais comme nous
nous l'avait dit ce que les américains
vont ils gagner au fond c'est de
l'indépendance des vols plus réguliers
vers la station spatiale internationale
alors que l'on voit les navires qui
s'approche de de la capsule kruja guinée
en terminant madame limoges
que dire de l'avenir de la relation
entre les américains et les russes qui
collaborait depuis dix ans pour envoyer
des astronautes à la station spatiale
vous savez on doit quand même qu'on sera
bien collaboré ensemble parce que on a
cette maison-là dans l'espace qui est la
station spatiale et c'est un lieu
international donc les américains et les
russes vont devoir continuer à
collaborer comme les autres nations
comme le canada japon l'union européenne
puis on va devoir continuer à apprendre
quand même le risque pour les américains
qui ont fait capable d'avoir de bonnes
relations
donc je pense pas que ça va faire 1 fois
et puis vous savez on voit de plus en
plus le de collaboration internationale
dans l'espace le géant récemment le la
nasa a annoncé que ça social agence
spatiale européenne pour le retour de
suspension de à partir de la planète
mars
donc qui sait comment la prochaine
collaboration que les pays bas vont
prendre forme